je sais qu'ici tous les chroniqueurs se
faisait une joie de recevoir 30 du boss
parce que vous trouvez qu'il a un
immense talent vous l'aimez
sur scène vous l'aimez au cinéma et moi
en plus c'était vraiment un ami quand
j'ai un ami c'est vraiment un homme nous
parler alain par jusqu'à cet après midi
mais voilà rien
chaque après midi franck quand même
voilà ça et je le dis devant la france
entière
tu m'a mis un coup de couteau dans le
dos dans le savoir h 30
je sais que tu prépares ton prochain
long métrage rumba la vie
il est ami et il écoute et franck c'est
toi qui a écrit ce film c'est toi qui va
réaliser ce film
malheureusement franck je suis tombé
sur cette petite annonce aujourd'hui au
maire d' homme 35 50 ans sachant bien
jouer au ping pong pour film franck
dubosc réalisé par et avec franck dubosc
et là ils cherchent quelqu'un sachant
très bien joué au ping pong pour ton
film et tu vas vous dire qu à aucun
instant tu n'as pense à moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enak partent en vacances correspond à 35
alors il cherche la campus ya pas alors
je vous le dis je vous dis dans le
cinéma
ja il ya normalement il ya figuration si
ça veut dire on te voit la mort de
treize silhouette c'est mieux le plus
bas c'est mieux d'en silhouette c'est
mieux silhouette c'est mieux là en
l'occurrence c'est mieux s'il ya une
partie de ping pong mais il est pas
obligé de jouer bien raison lancés ça
j'ai dit non il peut jouer mal ça fait
drôle aussi et tu penses plus seulement
maintenant que j'ai dit ça j'ai voyez
plutôt vers cyril hanouna
j'espère que voilà donc qui coûte si tu
veut pas de moi
faut que tu sais que tu fais pas tu fais
réfléchir là tout à coup en quoi c'est
une bonne idée à la menthe ou alors
entre le tonneau dit enfin on peut dire
et tout de suite ça ne te demandons rien
je reverserai le cacher au public mais
un âne ou alors c'est qu'on ne sait
combien ces 150 euros bon c'est vrai ce
qui parle de cacher ses 150 euros non
mais ce que ton officiel que les
assurances ou les assurances après le
revers se cacher mais est-ce que je peux
être dans ce [ __ ] de film thorax et
réclame la drève regarde la dre par
adresse adresse adresse et moi même
l'adresse sales et région parisienne
c'est complètement toi oui c'est pour
toi c'est vrai que j'ai pensé à jouer
si vous voulez quoi vous êtes capable je
suis capable de tout faire moi dans le
film je vous dis bien tous